voilà nous soyons prêts à saborder tous
les navires marchands qui croiseront
votre route pour un peu d'onet piraterie
au la nôtre arrive trop tôt beaucoup
trop tôt c'est toi qui lui a dit qu'elle
pouvait apparaître en premier cet
épisode concerne la piraterie je me
trompe je vous honore de ma présence
afin d'informer votre public sur mont
noble métier
oui en fait tu as quelques siècles
davance on a décidé de parler de la
piraterie en général à travers les
siècles bien tu sois très représentative
de la piraterie au xviie xviiie siècle
je suis pas sûr que tu puisses médias
grand chose sur l'antiquité par exemple
chou blanc
on rappellera quand ça sera pour tous
c'est ça à tout à l'heure
et c'est parti pour un historique de la
piraterie à travers les âges
quand on parle de la piraterie on pense
à tortuga ou tricorne et au perroquet
sur l'épaule mais j'avais envie dans cet
épisode de montrer une vision un peu
plus globale de la piraterie de ces
différents enjeux de ces différentes
formes
le bureau maritime international définit
la piraterie comme l'acte de monter à
bord d'un navire avec l'intention de
commettre un vol ou toutes autres sortes
de crimes et avec la capacité ou
l'intention d'utiliser la force non
nous reviendrons dans notre dernière
partie sur d'autres définition
contemporaine de la piraterie et sur les
problèmes juridiques qu'elles peuvent
poser en tout cas dès l'antiquité on
qualifie de pirates des bandits maritime
qui s'attaque à d'autres navires ou aux
villes portuaires la piraterie apparaît
ainsi dès l'apparition des nations
maritimes les auteurs de l'antiquité par
le fréquemment de pillage de vol
d'enlèvement comme homère dans l'odyssée
police s'attaque au peuple d'ethicon
égouts et pratique donc un acte de
piraterie dans la mythologie grecque il
existe également un épisode durant
lequel le dieu dionysos alcoolique
notoire se fait enlever par des pirates
dans l'espace méditerranéen on peut
citer dans un premier temps les
phéniciens qui vivent à peu près par ici
et qui domine le trafic méditerranéen à
partir des années 1200 avant
jésus-christ il pratique le commerce
maritime mais également la piraterie les
deux étant encore étroitement lié avec
l'expansion des cités grecques qui
dépendent elles aussi grandement du
commerce maritime le cas de la piraterie
commence à poser problème et ainsi que
les villes portuaires à se fortifier les
pirates de l'époque utilisent des
bateaux longs mais de plus petite taille
que les navires qu'ils souhaitent
attaquer ce qui les rend non plus
maniable et plus rapide ils sont
essentiellement d'origine grecque
crétoise ou d'asie mineure et la
piraterie se concentrent surtout dans la
partie orientale de la méditerranée dont
les côte très découpée et les nombreuses
îles sont propices au développement de
la piraterie des bases des pirates sont
souvent de petites criques dominée par
une hauteur ce qui ne manque pas dans
cette région leur permettant de guetter
les navires qui pourrait passer par là
et de cacher leur butin à rome les
pirates sont les principaux fournisseurs
d'esclaves et sont donc dans un premier
temps toléré il commence quand même à
poser problème à partir du 1er siècle
avant jésus-christ déjà ils commencent à
s'attaquer à des villes qui font partie
de l'empiré romain ce qui plaît
moyennement on veut bien des esclaves
mais il faudrait pas qu'en plus ils
viennent de chez nous ils kidnappent
aussi des sénateurs et autres
personnalités importantes contre une
demande de rançon comme césar en 75
avant jésus-christ qui juste après avoir
été libéré retourne voir ces pirates
pour leur péter là
et enfin de par leur activité il
commence à gêner le ravitaillement à
rome et ça ça n'est pas acceptable
cicéron définit les pirates comme les
ennemis de ti comme ça c'est pas
compliqué attention si tu préparent le
capes d'histoire-géographie ce passage
peut être utile en 67 avant jésus-christ
face à cette menace grandissante la loi
gars d'unia confie à pomper des pouvoirs
étendus afin qu'ils aillent régler une
fois pour toutes le problème de la
piraterie
il dispose d'un hymne période c'est à
dire d'une puissance militaire qui
s'étend sur toute la méditerranée
jusqu'aux colonnes d'hercule le détroit
de gibraltar et jusqu'à 75 kilomètres à
l'intérieur des terres c'est un grand
pouvoir pour l'époque et il implique une
grande responsabilité
il parvient donc à mettre pratiquement
fin à la piraterie en quelques mois en
délogeant les pirates de leurs repères
en méditerranée orientale
cicéron encore lui vante l'action de
pompey en déclarant au jour où vous
l'avez chargé de la guerre des pirates
on a vu grâce à l'espoir que donner le
nom d'un seul homme
le prix des denrées qui était
extrêmement rare et chère baisser tout à
coup comme après une récolte
extraordinaire et au sein d'une longue
robe nude et également contre la
piraterie en dehors de la méditerranée à
mesure que son empire s'étend contre les
pictes et les scandinaves en mer du nord
et en baltique
ils construisent pour cela des tours de
guet à la demande de léo dagan bien sûr
ce dernier passage par contre n'est pas
à citer dans +0 2 capes avec le déclin
de l'empiré romain la piraterie reprend
des forces au cours du premier
millénaire après jésus-christ en
méditerranée est également en mer du
nord
on a déjà parlé des vikings sur
lesquelles je ne reviendrai donc pas et
nous allons maintenant aborder la
piraterie
durant le moyen-âge la période préférée
au début du deuxième siècle la piraterie
change de forme mais pas d espace on la
retrouve en mer du nord en baltique et
en méditerranée dans le nord la manche
est un passage particulièrement
difficile comme on l'a vu en
méditerranée la piraterie se retrouvent
dans les espaces étroits comme les
détroit où les archipels
on trouve peu de piraterie en haute mer
ne serait ce que parce qu'il faudra
attendre des heures avant de trouver un
navire le commerce dans la manche est
donc très perturbé par la piraterie en
plus les états concernés la france et
l'angleterre ne possède pas de marine à
proprement parler pour régler ce
banditisme
on peut citer au xiiie siècle le cas de
stage le moine qui pratiquent la
piraterie 2205
à 1217 ans à cette date caïd meuf on
peut même le considérer comme une sorte
de corsair puisqu'ils pratiquent la
piraterie parfois au service de philippe
auguste pour la france et parfois au
service de jean sans terre pour
l'angleterre et pour saint georges
d'ailleurs un corsaire est quelqu'un qui
pratique la piraterie au nom d'une
nation il possède un petit papier qui
dit j'autorise ce bon monsieur avoue
pirater un corsaire au service de
l'angleterre que donc allègrement piller
les navires ennemis sans craindre d'être
inquiétés par lahouari en famille par
contre on est toujours le pirate de
quelqu'un d'autre
si tu es un brave corsaire pour les
anglais tu ne sera qu'un sale pirates
pour les français et vice et versa la
distinction entre pirates et corsaires
prend surtout de l'importance à l'époque
moderne que nous verrons par la suite
pour l'instant les deux termes sont
utilisés comme synonymes intéressons
nous à nouveau à la méditerranée
maintenant où la piraterie bat son plein
elle reprend progressivement avec
l'expansion musulmane et prend une telle
importance qu'elle freine le commerce
méditerranéen durant une grande partie
du deuxième millénaire
elle est principalement le fait de
dynasties berbères et arabes du maghreb
on désigne donc par le terme de
barbaresques la piraterie pratiquées
depuis maghreb entre le 16e et le 19e
siècle barbares berbère waouh c'est
principalement de la ville d'alger qui
sous domination ottomane que partent les
pirates malgré des tentatives de
répression inefficace de la part des
royaumes européens
charles quint par exemple s'attaque à la
ville d'alger en 1541 mais subit une
défaite cuisante
les pirates porte le nom de rails ils
sont principalement des corsaires au
service de la ville d'alger et pratique
le commerce d'esclaves grâce à leurs
prisonniers
c'est l'importance de cette piraterie
jusqu'au 19ème siècle qui explique en
partie d'intervention militaire de la
france en algérie à partir des années
1830 qui met fin à la domination
ottomane sur ces territoires et entraîne
le début de la colonisation du maghreb
mais le temps s'écoule comme dirait davy
jones et il ne sera pas dit que je
ferais une vidéo de plus de 15 minutes
aujourd'hui je vous donne donc rendez
vous la prochaine fois pour la suite de
cette formidable aventure à travers les
époques à la découverte des pirates en
parlant de rencontre je suis venu pour
rien alors c'est ça on t'avait dit que
tu étais en avance et on va même pas
tourner la suite aujourd'hui alors tu
peut ramer jusque chez toi on te
rappelles merci mais vous vous
rappellerez du jour où vous avez fait à
la prochaine pour un épisode sur la
piraterie du 17ème siècle à nove bonjour
chez vous merci